Hey bozo. Are you ready from my stylish moves?
My spinner's razor-sharp!
500 spins a minute!
1,000 SPM!
I-- impossible!
He's the perfect spinner.
Heartless.
Soulless.
I paid a lot to make him, and I'm going to win it all back once we take the grand prize.
I've sacrificed a lot to get here
Now, if I have this figured out, this competition is all about speed
and I've been practicing
all week!
What?! Why is the crowd booing?
Dabbing... it's not cool anymore.
This is the last opponent standing between me and
$100 in prize money. He doesn't stand a chance!
He's lighting the crowd on fire!
If I want to win, I'm going to need to focus.
It all started two years after the accident.
Brother!
They said my little brother would never walk again, but if I had $100 I could buy him some new bones.
Wait a minute...
that spin...
I've seen it before..
And now you finally know the truth.
The one who ruined your brother's life was me.
It was you!
There's no way I can win, not with this spinner.
But I still have one more trick up my sleeve.
Professor Okinawa made me promise to destroy it.
I'm gonna have to break that promise.
These psycho crystals could drive me insane.
It's my only shot at redemption.
Little brother, this is for you!
I can't get a measure on it!
He's off the spectrum!
We have a new champion!
Hold on, little brother.
I'm getting you some new bones!